I got arrested for the first time in
1981. I was eight Ben Baller is your
true rags to riches story growing up
from Los Angeles gang cultures
I'm saying representing that play
selling some of the most expensive
jewelry to the most famous people in the
world this includes people like Drake
Kanye West Mariah Carey Justin Bieber
John Mayer Mac Miller Kid Cudi and many
many more at Tupac there DJ to pick its
birthday there NFL Stars I met tons of
NBA players met Dr Dre there and got my
job from there all while being featured
in some of the most recognizable rap
lyrics of all time however all of that
recently came to an end when he decided
to abruptly quit today he's exposing
everything from growing his Empire
spending money and the secrets behind
all of his success on today's episode of
subscribe but first we're really excited
to announce today's sponsor HubSpot look
I could say from experience that running
a business could often feel like
juggling a whole bunch of things at the
same time and one of the most overlooked
aspects that most people don't even
consider is digital marketing that is
exactly where HubSpot comes in they've
recently acquired the hustle which is a
newsletter started with just one person
and is now skyrocketed to over 3 million
followers up spot in the hustle have
teamed up to bring you a comprehensive
guide on exactly what you need to do to
build an effective newsletter and I say
all of this as somebody who has a
newsletter already with over 40 000
people on it if you're not doing a
newsletter you absolutely should
consider it because it's so powerful
Graham that sounds really expensive the
good news is that this is completely
free and by signing up for the
newsletter you're not only gaining
access to Super valuable tips and tricks
but you're also becoming a part of the
hustle's thriving business Community
it's a place where entrepreneurs like
you can connect and watch other
businesses flourish now you might be
wondering are newsletters even relevant
in this day and age well when it comes
to digital marketing volume is key and
when done right newsletters can drive
thousands of visitors straight to your
website HubSpot provides the tools
expertise and strategies you need to
make your newsletter stand out and again
I'll tell you from first hand experience
having a newsletter is so important
because the people you reach that sign
up with the newsletter are the ones you
really want to reach out to so don't put
this off don't just think oh I'll do it
later take your business to the next
level with HubSpot so click the link in
the description to check out your free
newsletter building guide again it's
free that's f-r-e-e it's in like zero
dollars
thank you so much HubSpot and now back
to the podcast I am so excited to have
you on because I gotta say dude when it
comes to jewelry hip hop I feel like
you're a legend at this man like
immortalized in in rap lyrics too I feel
like in a sense dude I had like this
marketing company from NBC that did this
thing and I was like [__] I don't even
know I've been mention like 100 songs I
was like wow you've been mentioned in
100 songs yeah there's actually a huge
K-pop start I was looking at the door
and it was like a dress because make
sure
and someone's name is Jay Park here
whatever Jay Park is like the Diddy of
Korea he's you know K-pop is obviously
enormous you know BTS all that stuff he
was in a K-Pop group he was huge so he
has like three record labels now and
everything else in his last album
she has a hit single the name of the
song is Ben Baller so the only the hook
is about it just I was like what
I feel kind of weird about that bro and
then we shot the video up my story it
was just [__] weird just I always
forget about like things like that you
know but where'd you come up with the
name baller at the end where did that
come from um it came from playing
basketball because that was that was the
term on the street if you're a baller
yeah it was like right before being a
baller it's like a dude on the streets
who had money who was hustling and
getting you know getting bread or you
had bet but really baller was like in
that mid late 80s you were playing ball
like you actually haven't played yeah
you had skills playing basketball
baller shorts this and that and it was
just not and it changed completely to a
different thing you know which it all
transitioned correctly so that's
interesting uh what where did you get
your start you grew up in Los Angeles
right I was born and raised about
probably
get real geometry uh um
I would say what about four or five
miles from here yeah
um yeah I was born and raised in
Koreatown that's probably one of the
biggest gentrified areas and it was
really about a square mile Cape Town
probably occupies more area than
Hollywood now it's like it's it's
ridiculous how far it stretches born and
raised there
um predominantly Latino community
always been predominantly Korean owned
businesses
but then the Koreans really started
moving I saw this thing the other day
where people didn't believe me and I've
been saying it for
a decade at least maybe even two decades
Korean food in Los Angeles now in
Koreatown is better than Korean food in
Korea there's certain soups and stews
and certain recipes and certain things
in Korea that are going to always have
that
that you know I'm saying that sauce
but the money here is so big
that all the best chefs and all the best
cooks
have come to LA
and um
you could just go to any random place
it's hard to get bad Korean food here
Koreatown they want to make it look like
Korea there's certain things
infrastructure wise they can't do here
like for instance you know when you see
a billion that's four or five stories
tall
now there's three or four stories
underneath as well and you could be on
the fourth story
basement like you'd be on 4B
and have five bars on your phone like
how the [__] is this happening you know
what I mean like the Wi-Fi is incredible
you walk everywhere
but
just a weird thing like I love it and
sometimes I'm like I want to go
I could never live there what was your
childhood like my childhood was very
weird
um
dad's professor
also a pastor at a church what do you
teach Asian studies UCLA
my dad was had an Asian history there
for um 30 plus years my mom was a dress
contractor she sewed dresses in a
factory
um both of them working
early uh either one that were able to
take me to school sometimes after the
while they didn't so I was a latchkey
kid at an early age I was probably a
latchy kid I might be even as early as
six or seven we did have a nanny when I
was born my mom and dad came here
poverty stricken
um I think my mom came out 20 bucks or
something like that I had said 200 one
time in an interview and then my sister
was like what [__] you mean 20. and I
guess my brother had told me that my dad
went to jail for moving violation
because couldn't afford to pay it and
like even to the point where
I remember going to Candy getting candy
in the store I'm 50. Snickers Twix
whatever the [__] it was I remember when
Twix came out for the first time I saw
hold on you know I remember seeing these
candies and seeing like a Hershey's bar
or something and I remember it was 25
cents
I remember going when gas was like 19
cents like that I remember going and
seeing like a soda was 30 cents like a
Coke and you start seeing different
things
and so if my brother is eight years
older than me
can you imagine how cheap a piece of gum
or something was then and my brother ate
a piece of gum because he'd never been
in a store before he was like tripping
and um
he uh didn't pay for it just ate a piece
of gum and my parents were having a
panic attack
because they couldn't afford to pay for
that
which is crazy right and I've had this
fascination with liquor store since I
was a kid
and one thing my wife and my
mother-in-law noticed
like took maybe a couple years my
mother-in-law had said
Ben has a fascination with like liquor
stores and I always had because I was a
kid walking the streets so I was going
to liquor stores always used to be video
games in there arcade games and 25 cent
I would go there and that was like
arcade games Raised Me In the Streets
Raised Me I got arrested for the first
time in nineteen
81. I was eight you know I'm saying how
did you get arrested for it I was
stealing 82 so I was nine
I was stealing ColecoVision video games
out of Sears
and they had um a tent they had like a
thing where they were doing a renovation
inside Sears at the Cerritos Mall in
Cerritos California and they moved
everything outside and the security was
terrible what I would do was I would see
all these video games I loved legal
Vision [__] right I would take the video
games and shine them under the tent
then we go into the parking lot and go
on the other side and grab the [__]
things and I got away with it
our dumbasses me and my my boyfriend
we got on a bus
and we're bragging about 200 something
dollars I didn't know that was Grand
Theft Larson I had no idea actually it
was probably more than that because it
was Grand Theft Larson I think maybe it
might have hit it hit a certain point
whatever Grand Theft Larson was in 1982
and a security guard from Sears was on
the [__] bus with us oh man and then
by the time he goes hey man you guys are
like he wasn't aggressive
he was a big dude much bigger than us
we could have ran
and then we did so I was so scared
because my dad was such a bad he was a
big [__] he was like oh [__]
he's a Korean King Kong Bundy I don't
know if your King Kong bunny was that's
like a faint like Andre the Giant like
he was a famous wrestler so I stayed in
jail overnight because when you were
nine yeah they were asking me hey what's
your phone number what's your address
and I was like I don't know
what's your phone numbers I don't know
that's how scared I was to go home
because jail was going to be better than
me going you know what I'm saying was it
like a holding cell or something no I
was gonna sell I was in a holding cell
with actual [__] adults and
everything and every time new people
would come in they'd be like like
there's one chick it was like partying
just a white blonde chicks like what the
[__] are you in here for you know
because tell you the truth back then I
look like a good kid you know I had like
long hair whatever boom I looked like
you know I had decent clothes so they
were like what the heck and then at a
certain point there are some drunk dudes
there was some like pieces Pisa dudes
like you know dudes are just fresh off
the boat from Mexico there's a bunch of
random dudes there's some other there's
there's like a couple like there was
like maybe one Thug
and I was cracking jokes
so I had to jail cell crack in there
laughing and stuff and I'm nine the
sheriff came in and he goes [__] it's so
funny I was a man go [__] off I remember
him grabbing the back of my head and
slam my face against the wall and I was
like [__] you finally
my boyfriend kind of caved in his mom
found out
she came to pick us up
they called my parents
and my sister called the police station
remember this is different times this is
rotary phone no call waiting there's a
thing called emergency breakthrough if
you guys I'm familiar with that there's
no call waiting so if your phone's busy
they will call the operator and they'll
do emergency breakthrough to your phone
in fact this emergency breakthrough
someone needs to talk to you because
remember I always think about now like
what would you do like you're trying to
reach somebody yeah you just didn't you
missed out or whatever like if you know
you'd be like oh [__] there's someone
there they took off what are we gonna do
go call their cell phone there wasn't
cell phones I mean there was but it's
like there was I think maybe like in the
early 80s mid 80s but like
was like 19 a minute wait hold that
thought for a moment Ben because we just
teleported all the way back to our
studio to talk about something that's
extremely important and that would be
data privacy so we live in a digital era
which obviously is great for making
money but not so good when it comes to
your personal information now I didn't
tell you this Graham and it's a crazy
coincidence but just last week one of my
housemates Kevin had his identity stolen
and the thief has been trying to use
Kevin's identity to buy TVs and I kid
you not is destroying Kevin's credit
score don't end up like Kevin eliminate
this risk entirely and use today's
sponsor delete me delete me helps you
protect your personal data and keep it
private they specialize in removing your
personal information from data broker
websites so that you could have more
peace of mind knowing that your
sensitive Financial details aren't
floating around over the Internet delete
me even has a team of privacy experts
who take care of everything for you so
all you have to do is sign up so go to
jointheletme.com
ich20 or use promo code ich20 to get 20
off all consumer plans again that's code
ich20 at join deleteme.com protect
yourself stay private and Safeguard your
financial well-being with delete me
today and now with that said let's get
back to the podcast what was it about
the streets that you gravitated towards
what was I gonna do
it was really not nice for me to do so
play basketball and do that right your
parents are cool with that because they
weren't they were super strict thing of
like a professor would be he'd probably
be pretty buttoned up wanting his kid to
go down maybe the right path not like
hanging out so I was the youngest of
three
my brother and sister both went to
boarding schools our brother went to
school with the candidates
my brother went to school with the most
elite of elite there's no school in
Beverly Hills or even Stuyvesant like in
New York or I'm just trying to think of
any high-end level school it doesn't get
you know I mean it's up you know it gets
to the point where it's like even
Harvard and Yale and those Ivy League
Schools they're still in Ivy League
there's so few schools in a high school
system that have a history of Andover or
Exeter of Phillips Academy you know what
I mean my brother was there he was
brilliant you know he was a genius like
Beyond genius yeah almost to the point
where I didn't understand what the
Spectrum was until I started having kids
and you start realizing what like um
Asperger's is or certain things you know
like finding out Elon had it I almost
feel like my brother in Elon are a lot a
lot alike
um and my sister was also very brilliant
so they're in boarding school
so I was at home just [__] up
and I think that I was smart enough to
get good grades but my homework wasn't
very good so back in the day you would
get graded on tests you know your grades
but you also got great on conduct so I
could have an A in a class end up
getting a c or a d because my conduct
was so bad
like I would be in school and I remember
you know the teacher would call the
principal like pick up the phone again
you know phone with the wire
[Music]
and I'll be like [__] this I go get
scissors from arts and crafts and cut
the phone lines hello
hello hello hello because I know I was
gonna get in trouble like I would do
silly
like
like I just do I caused a lot of trouble
how did you not just get continuously is
yes well my parents got divorced when I
was 10 okay and I think that right there
was the end of everything and I think I
was really happy as a kid generally yeah
we ate dinner every night was my family
we um
it was a very big thing we had had
dinner we had to go to church we had to
do certain things it was a weird thing
then for like a little bit my mom
ghosted
I don't think my mom ghosted because she
didn't like my mom was getting her ass
whooped every day like my dad was
whipping her she was the breadwinner you
know my dad made I think at one point I
think he was making maybe up to 30 000 a
year as a [__] Professor you know
that ain't
and um my mom was just over it she's
like [__] this I can't do this anymore I
think she was sleeping at the factory my
mom worked 80 to 100 hour weeks
and she took off for a little bit and
it's like [__] this she left everything
like her clothes everything she's like
did someone start over and in a way I I
feel like
man me and my mom was so alike me and my
dad I really like my dad
he would tell me stories that he was
really wild as a young kid
um the crazy part is my dad was born in
Pyongyang
it wasn't North Korea then Korea was one
country how [__] crazy is that that
when the war happened my dad walked
across the [__] border you know what
I mean and then now at that point
there was no going back so North Korea
so that's a weird thing I don't know if
I've really even I've talked about on my
podcast I've never really talked about
it on a public podcast Forum you know a
platform but um yeah man I grew up in
the streets and everything else and then
I met this dude Eric Holmes
and um
he was like six two at like 13.
and he was from a [__] gang
and I was just fascinated with Crips
Crips you know I actually live in a
blood neighborhood surrounded by essay
neighborhoods right by all Mexican gangs
and I was fascinated with the culture I
don't know what it was I was obsessed
with hip-hop I was break dancing I was
winning break dance contests you know in
the early 80s I was able to go to New
York as a young kid
you know what I mean go try to find
Rocksteady crew and beat street and all
that stuff and just doing I was
completely submerged in hip-hop culture
from the graffiti aspect to the DJing to
hip-hop in every possible form
but I also love basketball and there was
a park one block away from me called
Ardmore Park
I can't tell you how many members must
have happened at this [__] park right
create towns is still a pretty decent
area but if you go to some CD Parts
you'll see some [__] you know and then
there's an area called Chateau Park
where it's like
it could get real ugly right there
that's kind of like almost at a border I
don't even know if you would call it
Koreatown but you could because it's
like across the street and it was just
like this little area that we grew up in
so I think my parents got divorced I had
transferred so much
from fifth grade
sixth grade to my freshman year in high
school
I went to six schools
that's a lot I remember getting
transferred to one school
first day didn't know anybody there
was affiliated with like a little gang
and this and that and this was a school
where and most people know that live in
la la I don't know how it works anywhere
else because I think that this is like
that this was a capital gang culture you
know when it comes but like our school
had like you know when you see like
valedictorian whatever Boom the
principal's office there was areas in
office where they actually had all the
gangs that were there and they had the
people
line up and they had [__] gang
pictures are updated every year yeah if
you're in 18th Street whatever boom you
know you're from the hell rats you're
from The Rockwood Street you're from The
Rascals whatever Diamond Street they had
all the gangs lined up my first week at
this school
I've been there on the first day
and I kicked this kid in the style game
with Charlie Horse I don't know who the
[__] kid was kicked out right there
why why'd you why do you have no idea
why I just felt like I didn't want to
remember why you kicked him don't even
know I honestly think that he really had
no I don't think he had a reason to be
kicked you just I gave a knee right to
his to his thigh the game of Charlie
horse and he fell down and he started
crying my transcript was already bad any
of these transcripts get sent here and
there I think after three days they're
like yo you're out of here so finally I
went to a Catholic School
Catholic School it's like you know
they're not gonna [__] around at all
and there's like you know Sister Mary
this blah blah there's nuns
and I got all the way through the year
battling through [__] all this other
stuff wearing a uniform
on the last [__] week of school
I got caught flipping off the nun why
did you flip off the nun I didn't know
she was she was such a [__]
so what'd you do man ready she was just
she was she was a miserable
they call my dad's office at UCLA my
brother's a lot older than me yeah my
brother happened to be home from college
picked up my dad's office phone
and acted like my dad and worked out a
deal with the school because only one
week of school left
I said let him do all this this that's
normal brother's genius yeah he got a
1580 on his sat at 14. in the my dad put
him in the hospital because he didn't
get a perfect score
like put him in and every time I think I
got my ass beat every single time like I
think about getting hit by a belt like
450 times like cruel like he would do
like put me in the bathroom turn the
lights off maybe sit on my knees for 30
minutes by the time you get up I don't
care how young you are or how resilient
you are you can't walk because you're
like sore you know you have cramps or
anything then you get up and you get
smacked like you would just do crazy
[__] my dad was like you know I would
have to wear long sleeves on a hot day
because I have so many lashes on my arms
and stuff my brother got beat worse than
I did and I regardless like imagine
getting knocked the [__] out
how do you want you're not gonna you
know someone else gets it worse it's
like Jesus Christ you know yeah my
brother was able to work out a deal
where I would still graduate
seventh grade was it eighth grade I
forgot seventh grade I think and not go
to school turn my homework every day and
he would do it and my brother would just
basically every morning act like he was
taking me to school
he would take me to Venice Beach to go
work out at Gold's Gym boom whatever
this he would do the homework and he's
like I should kick your
for being a [__] up I can't believe this
what we understood like I was the
youngest I was [__] up
finally my dad was like look
I don't want to pay for Catholic school
anymore
move into a 630 square foot apartment
one bedroom [__] apartment me my dad
my sister
part-time my brother one but this was a
[__] tiny place never forget 360
South Rexford Drive in Beverly Hills so
I could be in the Beverly Hills School
District so I went to Beverly Vista at
that school
um there was a kid
a Russian kid
that was a child maker and I was like
[__] [__] [__] Beverly
Hills is [__] [__] but I live in
an apartment building you know what I'm
saying so it was like it was a weird
thing Russian kid
was a graffiti artist I was like who is
this clown now mind you most graffitios
you'd be 16 17 18 or something like
they're not going to be many graffiti
artists are 13 or 14. but I ran with the
older crowd always so I was the guys
were driving you know what I'm saying
when I was getting kicked out all the
schools and gang banging and stuff I was
hanging out with one of the most
notorious graffiti crews in the world
this dude ended up actually joining a
rival group because he's from the west
side I'm all the way you know you know
anywhere from Boyle Heights to downtown
L.A to like Koreatown
and um
he's right rescue
and he was Russian
and I thought he was like whatever
anyways
fast forward
this dude end up being in a massive
hip-hop group called House of Pain DJ
lethal then after that he was even a
bigger rock band called Limp Biscuit
yeah so you know like me or me and litho
always been cool and it was like a weird
thing and we've always been cool like
I connected with him there then when you
know I finished there I actually like
that school
there was hot chicks I was like damn
these chicks if there's like girls are
just beautiful people are rich even if
you weren't you were still privileged or
didn't drive whatever and I'm like wow
this is kind of all right it was cool I
went to school with rayman's Eric's son
Pablo rayman's Eric was one of the
members of The Doors the most famous
rock bands ever
so it was like a really cool thing I
don't care we're poor and then we live
in this little small place so now I go
to Beverly Hills High
Menendez brothers
Monica Lewinsky's one of my closest
friends and his brothers were there yeah
they were there in my mind I got in a
fight with [__] Lyle or Eric like
like my first week there so how did you
get into a fight with Eric Menendez I
was a freshman playing football remember
just walking past
and um
even though it's a big school
now Beverly Hills High School is the
only High School in Beverly Hills yeah
there's like a small private school like
there's a couple Jewish academies
and I remember passing through going to
the swim gym
which is the gymnasium that has a
swimming pool for water polo and for
swim meets and has a
basketball gym on top of that like an
opening one this is a pretty dope school
I'd end up getting in a fight with this
dude like oh I shouldered him you know
freshman was kind of senior
didn't realize later I was like holy
[__] like later later like all that
happened in real time you know what I
mean it was crazy there was kids driving
to school and Porsches BMWs and things
like that and I was like whoa anime and
some really cool people at a young age
at 15 I met Nicole Eggert and she was
already on a hit TV show called Charles
in Charge and I was like obsessed with I
was like in love with this girl my
friend was dating her she ended up being
the other girl outside of Pamela
Anderson on the number one show in the
world called Baywatch me and Nicole
Nicole just sent me a picture the other
day
it's like I've known you a long time
like I saw the other day I saw her like
three or four years ago when I bought my
new house and had a Fourth of July party
and this and that anyways
me and Monica Lewinsky had like four or
five classes together
one kid that was in my class that was
always quiet was on my football team
I saw him get dropped off in a black
Testarossa now mind you in 1988 this is
Miami Vice
a black Testarossa that's literally like
that's that's as cool as me dropping off
my kid in a [__] in a La Ferrari it
was a big [__] deal and the kid's
name is James purse it's enormous
designer yeah we were talking the other
like a couple weeks ago
now think about how many kids went to
school David Schwimmer Richard Dreyfus
Lenny Kravitz went to my high school and
there's so many different people so
obviously because I was in hip-hop I
gravitated towards you know any of the
black kids I went to school there one of
the kids I went to school with me is
doing named Chauncey
she ended up being a famous rapper named
loon on Bad Boy no Tammy had a couple of
really big hit songs and um it was crazy
like when I think back now like CW has
won the number one shows which was
Netflix's number one show called
All-American it's still on the air now
the show All-American is based on my
football team on my coach and my boy you
know what I mean his dad was crazy like
that whole show was based on that it's
kind of like why do you think so many
people graduated from Beverly Hills High
School do you feel like it's it's the
money do you feel like it's the
connections everybody in the same place
do you feel like it's maybe just
coincidence I think that one you get a
great education they had a really high
return I think it was like 70 something
percent went to college
um if your family worked for the city
whether it be in sanitation what you
know you could be poor person yeah if
your family worked for the city my boy
Greg Holmes his dad was in sanitation
and you know you look at sanitation like
dude yeah it's a trash man dude [__]
what up I never knew Trashman made six
figures in the [__] 80s these guys
get paid you know they're getting money
firemen whatever
and um
I just think that people wanted to go to
a good they want they rather be in a
good school you know back in the day
Westwood was the place to hang out in
Westwood now it's like whatever there's
you know there's the Grove there's this
but you want to go to Westwood to see a
movie that's why everyone cool was going
to Westwood all the movie premieres were
in Westwood all the celebrities going to
Westwood the Olympics were in town in 84
and all this that was going on but yeah
you know I ended up getting kicked out
of Beverly
why'd you get kicked out of Beverly I
was running a
well two things
I was smoking cigarettes and I was
running a gambling uh a bookie you know
I was a bookie the dude I got kicked out
of school with his name is Tommy
Woolfolk lucky I am from a very big
hip-hop group that was like a legendary
group there's a dude named Murs from his
group and like Murs was really famous he
was doing commercials and everything
well it got kicked out now I'm thinking
[__]
what am I going to do how do you get
caught I mean people are losing money
and they're reporting no because they
lost money yeah now were you taking a
rake on that or like were you getting
paid or were you just facilitating maybe
Realty man yeah there was a couple kids
I knew I could Punk
and like they'd lose and I would
obviously collect
and then one kid I remember one year in
the Super Bowl he won and I just thought
I said [__] you man no yeah I was like I
think that's what what ended it um
um was it like a negligible amount of
money or was it something like it was a
couple hundred bucks that's a lot of
money back then you understand how huge
that was so there was a kid that lived
in the borderline of Beverly Hills I
don't know how he went to school there
he was always hustling he was always
fast talking he was always this he today
is probably one of the biggest Moguls
still in music and everything his name's
gal Siri
guy is a part owner of Maverick manages
Madonna
he uh created board API Club one of the
founders of yoga Labs all that stuff and
I can't even imagine Uber like so many
different things I gravitated to him
because he was always down to hip-hop he
was throwing parties he didn't come from
like Beverly Hills Beverly Hills and he
was like you know he was a Jewish kid
but he was like it was a trip and half
my family was Jewish so it's like it was
like a weird thing that was going on in
my family and me and guy always cool
when he said he was gonna start a record
label there was uh at the time Madonna
was the biggest star in the world female
wise she was enormous her manager
Freddie the man
she his daughter went to our high school
so like he became really friends with
her later on met ended up being a big
dude
guy straight out of high school had like
three groups one group was a Beverly
Hills West Side rap group called proper
grounds
then he had a group called The rentals
and then he had two guys one group that
was [__] their their legendary the
Deftones like legendary rock band but he
found this girl named Alanis Morissette
and she sold [__] like 30 40 million
records and just off signing her alone
he became filthy rich
and to this day I know guy you know a
guy's still killing it and everything
but I think I made so many connections
there you know when I got kicked out I
was like [__] what am I gonna do
like my only chance is to play ball I
end up transferring
thank God I was um All City all CIF
Allstate I didn't make All-American
but I was good enough to wear you know I
had 11 touchdowns my sophomore year then
my junior year I had 17 touchdowns which
is a record and I was a wide receiver
and a free safety I had [__] up so
much I got kicked out of my school in
junior year my new school
did I had to move to this small little
tiny area how did you get kicked out of
the school as a junior what did you do
this time it was everything you could
think of smoking weed you name it just
all that [__]
now eligibility for the NCAA was 2.0 800
SAT score I did pretty bad in the SAT
bro I got like a 1060.
which of my family was like disgraceful
I ended up getting
um a 1300 after that and when you when
the score jumps up 200 points now you
know they do a review because that's too
high even if you're going through you
know all the programs and stuff anyways
I was beyond academically available I
think I ended up graduating high school
with like a 2.7 which was a disgrace
because my brother's like a 4.9 and my
sister was like a 4.2
I didn't get to play football my senior
year in high school at this small little
town called Albany in California it's
just an outskirts suburb of Berkeley
my brother was going to school at Cal
I still end up getting a scholarship at
Cal
now I didn't want to leave the Bay Area
I didn't want to leave la
and I beg my family I was like please
like look you have no other chance you
know dude which want you to go to school
my dad had the dean of [__] of of the
Asian studies at UCLA write me a letter
recommendation we're willing to pay you
know my dad had a certain fee I think it
would have been like 700 bucks a
semester so it would have been like 1400
a year which is insane for UCLA I think
UCLA is probably 20 something thousand
now but it was amazing I was gonna walk
onto the football team I had a
guaranteed prefer to walk on
I couldn't even get in UCLA
because like 900 000 applicants that had
4.0 were Asian you know I know this
affirmative action thing is really big
right now but that's the real thing if
you go to the UC system school you know
right now it's like
I'm not joking you I would say if you
gathered all the UC system schools right
now
it would be at least 72 Asian it's that
ridiculously high and they're turning
away millions of people
so yeah man you know I end up uh playing
ball
um
I always say if I never went to college
I'd probably be I would have been a
multi-millionaire early
my boy got it offered me a job
when I finally finished school
you know I'd connect with some people
got back into scene I feel like I was
four years late now my boy blew up he's
got a couple bands a lot of more sets
about to come out he's getting things
going
and I hit him up and he's like hey
what's up dude how you doing bro hey I
gotta go man I'll talk to you later kind
of shine me and I'm saying just kind of
just wrote me off
and I always kind of resented that but
at the same time like
I might I probably would do the same
thing like he was doing big things I was
you know trying to play ball
thought about trying to go play Pro in
the overseas
didn't even last in 30 days it was in
Beijing was like [__] this I couldn't
live here you tried you went yeah
and uh why didn't you like Beijing
though
oh Bro Look Beijing today I'll never go
back to imagine Beijing in 94. like I'm
being serious like it was like you could
eat breakfast there for like eight cents
that's all I need to say like I'm just
trying to let you know like the soup in
this it just wasn't where I was I was in
Beijing last five years ago
and I said to myself I'll never come
back here ever again I remember being
stuck in traffic for three and a half
hours to go
32 miles yikes and then
I asked them to get me a helicopter I
was like I can't be in this dude I can't
be in this printer you got to get me a
helicopter I don't give a comment your
costs
I ended up
was able to to get out
get to my destination in 22 minutes
everyone else that was stuck there and I
won't name their names because it's
[__] up and some of these guys own
famous clothing brands
you're not ready for this where are you
from Ventura where are you from here all
right so think about it
so you exit Highland
next as it's uh Universal or Barham
because after that is Ventura X after
that is Vineland Laurel Canyon Coldwater
Canyon Woodman
Van Nuys Sepulveda Haskell dude good
memory man I'm just thinking just think
about his face you're hitting them all
exits in China were like 10 and a half
miles mind you it was an hour to get you
know
a mile and a half these guys who didn't
get it with me in the helicopter
had a nine and a half hour drive back
they dude missed the exit and it was a
10 month I make a U-turn these guys were
Snapchatting
while they would take off walk to an
exit seven eight miles get cigarettes
get a drink whatever boom find whatever
they could come back and the car moved
like
half a mile
like like that like it was crazy why is
traffic so bad it's just been terrible
and you know everything's controlled by
the government so like on certain days
white cars can drive certain days
license plate just depends so really
rich people have different color cars
and different license places like that
but anyways you know I came back was
able to meet Denzel Washington was able
to connect with some other people got a
job gotten a music business how do you
connect with these people and get a job
like that so from being in high school
at Beverly
there was a radio station at Beverly
called kbev what's crazy is dude I mean
Mike Karen ran the label Mike Karen
today is probably one of the most
powerful people in music Still he's the
president of Atlantic Records I can't
even begin to tell you how many but he's
enormous and he's been there since you
know back then this radio station
produced you know some major [__] it was
a weird thing she's like Beverly Hills
man [__] that but
there is a group that will sign a soul
assassin Soul assassin's disciples and
Cypress Hill was huge house of pain was
[__] huge Funk dubious was huge at
this time they're a group called The
Hooligans Hooligans consisted of two
people well three a DJ but Alchemist my
boy Alan who still to this day is one of
the most prominent probably one of the
most prolific producers in hip-hop
history and a dude named Scott Khan yes
his dad James Khan late great James Khan
one of the most famous actors in the
world they were in a rap group together
and they were killing it and so there
was like a buzz going on on the west
side
so there was this club that we had in
Hollywood my boy Nick Adler my boy Dave
Faustino who at the time had the number
one TV show on the first you know I love
him man So Married with Children was no
one show in the world Not only was the
number one show in the world even after
that it was the longest running
syndicated show in the world so residual
checks were just insane for him
so Dave Faustino my boy Dan Einstein
went to Beverly with me my boy Nick went
to Bradley for a little bit my best
friend of my life is Dallas my godfather
they created a club called ballistics
and they're still making a documentary
about it I don't know what's going on
with it I filmed for it but
this club had Easy E exhibit we'll we'll
let you know Will I Am was will win X
back then NWA countless hip-hop dudes
that were going to this club at the
Whiskey A Go Go
so I met all these people there
Nick Adler told me that
his dad was gonna be a small investor in
this restaurant a Jamaican restaurant
called Creek alley on Melrose
and um he couldn't really plug me the
way he wanted to but he can give me some
ideas I saw Denzel Washington on Melrose
Avenue walking out of Georgia the other
restaurant that he owned
and um it's right there on Martel well
Alta Vista and Mark so it's literally
right down the street from here he's on
Melrose
walking and his car is parked in front
of Spike Lee's store which obviously at
the time Malcolm X was one of the
biggest movies in the world walking out
of the the Spike Lee store um 40 acres
of mule
and I've been waiting for him and I had
a tape and I was like yeah here's my
tape listen to my tape
a week later the assistant Tish caused
me a call and I get a job there from
there the rest is history what was on
the tape my mixtape
I want a DJ at his at his restaurant
he's like we don't do details like no in
New York that's the style let me set the
vibe let me do it for a hundred dollars
a night which was way under like you
know I was like look I'll work seven
nights a week I'll set the music up I'll
play jazz I'll play Vibes I'll play this
this and this there's a point in time
where it got a little too hoodie felt
like because it was like a really
upscale place it was only it was amazing
Jamaican food
I met Tupac there my DJ Jada Pinkett's
birthday there I um
met NFL Stars I met tons of NBA players
I met Dr Dre there and got my job from
there I met sug what was that like
meeting Dr Dre
I met him like seven times
and I've told this story several times
he would frequent Freak Alley he'd love
this place you know I sit at the bar
there's so many girls there this and
that and the DJ booth was on the top of
the restaurant so I could see everything
and one night
Denzel Nick Adler's dad all the owners
of the restaurant went on a private jet
to go watch Oscar De La Hoya fight
and they told me I said no [__]
hip-hop tonight no [__] imma shoot
this [__] here this out of there and I
was like yeah don't worry about it it's
all good
my boy Grant was a manager I was like
Grant
I will give you everything I have I'll
give you some coke I'll give you
anything bro please let me do my thing
tonight he's like what I think you were
like talking to five different girls at
times again what the [__] you want to
give a [__]
all the TVs in there it was a sports bar
too yeah
I turned all the TVs to black
exploitation films the Mac [__] you
know what I'm saying like um um um shaft
all the crazy movies yeah Dre gets there
early like 9 45 this place jumps off at
like 11 30 remember La last calls early
I started vibing out all 70s 60s James
Brown 70s start going through 80s
I get to you know in its mid 90s so I
get to the late 80s
starting to kind of dabble in the
hip-hop classic [__] more East Coast
stuff I go down to get a drink and I get
a drink where he's sitting instead of
going to the where I'm like opposite
side yeah and I know he's gonna talk to
me
because I'm [__] murdering this place
and um
now I forget so crazy dude named Arthur
was a bartender I was like Hey Arthur
man
let me get a Long Island Iced Tea
I had heard the people that that was Dr
Dre's favorite drink I think to this day
it still is so Dre is like probably
about as far as he is and he goes
and Dre and my brother are born in the
same year
hey youngster
what you know about that Music Man
[__] you mean I grew up on that [__]
he was blown away that Asian dude had
known so much about hip-hop and stuff
and I was born and raised in the hood
and everything
so we started talking he's like all
right man he's like you [__] my mind
up right now and I was like oh we ain't
even got started yet now 11 30. I have
it cracking in there like everyone they
mother you know
a week later he Pages me
I end up at Can Am Studios death row
Studios and I mean start working with
them what were you doing with them at
the time scratches inserts bringing
breaks brakes are like samples and music
and stuff like that going through things
whatever boom so it was a scratch like a
like an actual like yeah like literally
there wasn't like there's not the things
are going now you know what I mean I
scratched like [__] you you know what I
mean wow hell no you know whatever it
was just scratch into inserts and stuff
and like really to tell you the truth
almost any DJ that was decent could do
that but if you Vibe well you know like
why not put somebody on how many how
easy is it for an extra to say hey
not even saying like one line and they
get their sag card right for acting
whatever it could be so easy like oh
just walk on a bus how [__] hard is
that for you to do you know like Brad
Pitt he worked at [__] El Pollo Loco
panning out flyers I mean anyone just
about who you can you're connected to
right
I was lucky I was there and then that
led to a job of priority records
in two years I was vice president and
then there left there we got Jay-Z to
Jay-Z's first album did all Masterpiece
[__] ice cube was huge left started off
with entertainment with Dre and when you
do these jobs with these artists what
exactly is your role in them are you
giving feedback
to like you know on a music level yeah
so a r means artist and repertoire yeah
back in the day prior to my time now I
can't even know what the [__] annoy
does now
a r is a full spectrum you don't just go
find the talent you groom them you can
actually play an instrument you
understand and I was a DJ I was in the
music you're going to the studio you're
listening to sounds you're part of the
marketing plan you have the whole Vision
to sales everything
now there's to be 60 deals back in the
day labels could never touch your tour
money could never touch your merch money
is that whatever it's all connected you
know it's different times then
publishing whatever so I was coming up
with marketing plans I was coming with
Styles coming up with who to collab with
do certain things it would be different
things for everyone
you know on Jay-Z's album I connect them
with the only R B group that we had at
the label that was a group on their mind
I connected writers I would do
everything you could think of I was
literally put everything together a damn
near manager in a way yeah I was that
connected to these groups and I was so
passionate about it that I fell in love
with every group that I was I was
representing how was the money on
something like that for me to make six
figures
in the early 90s at you know [__] 24
years old like
that's insane you know I'm saying 23 I
was the youngest vice president of the
company like that was crazy to drive a
Lexus to live in a ball and ass [__]
apartment building I lived in on a
broadcast Center I lived on top of
arawan market and this is when everyone
wants oh everyone's so cool in that
[__] I was going and I wanted
[__] the 90s Tupac lived in my
building how much [__] cooler is that
yeah Russell Simmons Tupac Bone um one
of the Bone Thugs dude in my building
Sally Richardson was a really famous
black actress back then I had a lit ass
life the only thing was I was living Way
Beyond my means
and I really appreciate the fact that I
went so [__] hard and lost all that
money I went I went broke three times
before I turned 30. how much were you
spending it wasn't that it was just like
you know you don't understand taxes you
don't understand this you're like all
right [__] this you know all right I'm
gonna claim three I got no kids yeah
like I wanna take three or four
deductions no you know boom whatever you
ever audited then yeah of course what is
that like I mean you just go through
stupid [__] you know you're just like
it's just dumb you owe the IRS money
here and boom and but again that's small
potatoes you know it's like this is
nothing it was like you know and then
you know I was DJing so I had cash money
and had this and just
it was until around
2001 or 2002 where I started finally
having like five grand in the bank six
grand started saving money
and then finally you know 2004 I became
a millionaire and not from any kind of
work
I'm [__] selling sneakers from a
hobby that I had that was a passion
again
you know so explain this how you made a
million dollars selling sneakers so
you're collecting these sneakers over
time and you sold the collection so I've
been a sneakerhead since the 80s even
when I was getting arrested at Sears I
was always wanting to be a fresh
sneakers
around my time at the record label
I started to collect sneakers so in the
mid 90s I was collecting sneakers
throughout that time I was collecting
rare sneakers that weren't being
reproduced they barely started retroing
Jordans
around 2002 I got a marketing job with
Nike minority had been David in the
sneaker Community now it's Discord but
back then it was forums you know and I
was heavily part of a world famous
legendary Forum called Nike talk and I
just created this buzz and I was doing
all these things and I was planting
Force marketing that people didn't
realize I was doing this [__] I get
crazy rare shoes
a couple pair of the shoes that I sold
flight
20 grand I was like damn I got 20 grand
for a pair of shoes and all four million
dollars a pair right now you know like
stupid [__] I exited the sneaker game
early
I had a falling out with Nike my shoe
was supposed to come out it was going to
be a Nike Terminator I was super excited
didn't work out didn't happen I said
[__] Nike [__] them I didn't wear Nikes
for eight years
I only wore bands and Adidas and
everything else I was that and it was to
the point where they were telling people
from high-end Nike accounts hey if Ben
Baller is at your store and promoters on
the internet we're gonna pull your Nike
account
that's how much drama there was funny
thing is they end up sending me the most
rarest pair of Yeezys when no one can
get a pair
to like as a good faith like hey we've
changed you know blah blah whatever but
anyways I end up selling all the shoes
they gave me all the shoes I collected
about 1800 pairs of sneakers and it was
two different auctions one for 2.9
Million another one for like 330 it was
like 3.2 million dollars two questions
one where do you store 1800 pairs of
shoes and then two why sell so I had
three bedroom apartment in Sherman Oaks
California
right by Whole Foods never forget this
place my boy meth amphibian who we had a
sneaker customization company with lived
there and we just stacked them on top
like a [__] Warehouse it was like
crazy and I remember my boy we had a
crew called Air Max crew me DJ AM rest
in peace was one of the most famous DJs
ever spawned the queer so many people
and DJ homicide who was in a rock band
called Sugar Ray and he had been killing
it each of us all had 600 pairs of shoes
I just went mental in a certain point
each one of our parents were like
you know how to pair of shoes a lot of
pair of shoes
300 400 pairs is ridiculous right
five six hundred you know maybe
something's wrong with you like
seriously people think something's slow
off with you 1800 bro I can't even you
know we can't even talk about that right
um would you wear these shoes or did you
just buy some did you if I didn't like a
pair of shoes I would buy two three
pairs
if I loved them I had five pairs no way
yeah did you think these would be an
investment or you just yeah I know
immediately I know immediately I knew
why just because they were so hard to
get the man was crazy when I was typing
Nike dunk on eBay yeah in the early
2000s like 2001 2000 whatever
you would see 47 [__] results and out
of 47 maybe seven were actually real
dunk results if you do it now there
might be something Millions
like I was early in the game and I
didn't want us [__] why would I want
to hold Nikes you know it wasn't going
to be like a bubble or like maybe for
like a few years someone was gonna that
was the only thing I was assured thing
about really I was a sure thing I was a
fair I was a huge advocate for that I
started like these rooms called stock
room picks and this and that and the
reselling [__] like I was literally like
at the Forefront of it you know I was a
Pioneer in that whole game and all the
OG people who were still alive and this
you know sneaker resale space
like they're like damn man you got out
of that great time I wish I got out
around 0.607 sure I got a little tour
with that have been worth had you just
waited a few years
you could have never told me because I
never I never had a million dollars
before you know
like that was a big deal for me you know
so um do you think though if you waited
you might have like three million bucks
you're like well I had 3.2 yeah I would
have had eight if I waited L6 oh wow
okay been a huge difference yeah I was
going through a lot of my life at that
point it was the first time I was ever
engaged in my life I think I've always
been the same person
but that enhanced you know having money
I remember going to the ATM and I'm at
the Times 500 is the most you could take
out at an ATM
I would take out 500 every single day
and I thought that was a big deal for me
I was like oh [__] this who cares man
let's go have fun blah blah see a chick
like [__] that I got you don't worry
about it drinks I got it boom whatever
it just you know
just being Hood Rich being stupid and
that's after you got the 3.2 million
yeah Ferrari you know what I'm saying so
you bought a Ferrari yeah
what Ferrari about a 360 challenge for
Dolly oh no way yeah in real time too so
that was like oh that was crazy yeah and
that's must have been when the car just
came out just came out I love that car
yeah of that money did you think like
hey I got to invest this I got to play
it smart or was it like this is so much
compared to what I ever thought I would
make well I knew at that point I was
good for a little bit at least
and pretty early on the engagement was
called off
I got caught cheating
and she didn't even catch me if that
makes any sense
she was so tied into me
and she was in [__] Germany she's a
supermodel
and she would call me like at midnight
or like 11 pm when she'd wake up for a
shoot and one night I didn't pick up the
phone and she just knew and we were that
we were that aligned and I think she
just knew I was out with Little John and
at a party whatever boom and I'm going
to Vegas and um
she felt the vibe off
and I think she was also going through
some [__] in a way I was a great [__]
thing that happened
I don't think I was ready to get married
and then anyway so
um at that point I traveled the world
and that's when I knew that like
seeing the world and become more worldly
that's when I knew that
I didn't need a lot of money
to just really soak up a lot of game
and then came back was like all right I
need to figure something out because I
can't do this forever and that's when I
transitioned and pivoted into a jewelry
I got a question about the cheating if
you're cool to answer about it so what
was your how did you rationalize getting
with somebody else when you had a fiance
at the time did you think oh I could
just not get away you know what it was
funny I'll tell you this right now
I never really worried about cheating
because I never really stayed with a
girl long enough you know that was the
longest relationship I've been to my
entire life and how long were you with
her two and a half years maybe that was
a long time for me and she was so
beautiful and I think everything else
was so right that I was so in love with
her mentally and everything else I think
her being away so much to Europe and all
this other [__] and gone
I just got horny it was simple as that
and it didn't really mean anything but
did you think oh she's gonna find out
it's gonna cause complications I had
zero that didn't think twice about I was
like [__] this
this is going down why get engaged at
that point though
like isn't it better just not get
engaged I thought I was ready I thought
this was a good but then it just you
know impulses came up and you just yeah
it was just you know again look if I
think about who I was at 31 who I am
tonight now that was 20 years ago right
of course of course you know I was a
[__] I was that was stupid as [__]
did did you think about her when making
this decision to sleep with this other
person or were you just like no this is
she was in the back of my mind for sure
in the back of your mind and especially
when the phone rang
when the phone rang I'll never forget we
had two phones and one phone me and her
had a phone together the Sprint phone
and I'll never forget this silver little
flip phone and when the phone rang I was
like [__]
was like damn
and I remember like I went to bed I woke
up
it was like maybe 9 A.M so that's what
like 6 p.m their time and I called she's
like hey what's up she was already weird
I went to go visit her mom drove to her
mom's house
and
I was like damn man I miss her so much
you know blah blah whatever this and
that and she's like yeah it's crazy
and then a door opened up
and she flew in La without telling me
instead of her mom's house I was like
what the [__] are you doing like the
[__] going on
I was like oh my God I was so shocked
I took her I was like let's go get some
food you know boom went to [__]
Marina Del Rey to get some food we were
talking
and then she was trying to tell me that
things ain't gonna work out I didn't
understand like we lived together like
what the [__] going on you just went
to your mom's like you're staying there
it was weird and it was like a weird
vibe now I really still couldn't get it
and then I remember
um
at a Porsche 911 at the time
pulled over in the middle of the road
and I was like yo are you trying to say
you like that's it and she's like I'm
trying to say yeah that's it at the time
what was crazy was she had fallen in
love with another dude
like an older man hmm
because I know her well enough to know
like she was dressing slightly different
she was walking Cartier stuff which she
had money
but it was like it was weird and I was
like
wait a minute
and then I was like all right it's time
to go so I went through a pretty I was
sad because it was my fault I felt bad
and the [__] up part about it is I
never admitted that something was wrong
I just you know what I'm saying she
never knew yeah
funny part about it was
when me and my wife first started dating
14 13 14 years ago
I ran into her
and I felt obligated to say something
and then
um it was awkward I was having dinner
with my brother my sister my dad
my wife and I think
the two boys were alive that was it
she was in the same Korean restaurant
with three friends of mine
my boy Jerry Lorenzo who owns fear God
it's a really small circle you know
whatever another guy I knew and then her
husband and her kids it was like a
really weird thing she walks over
because my dad a big hug because my
sister a big hug gives my brother a hug
my family's like why would they have a
problem with her because it was me being
super right my wife had kind of known
my wife was real weird about it
so it was like a weird thing so I was
like ah [__] it it is what it is sure so
did you admit later and say hey I
screwed up I did I told her like I told
her like I was like Hey listen I just
want you to know
do you remember that night you called me
and she was like yeah
I was [__] some stupid ass [__] in
in Vegas and she was like I know you was
doing something off
and at that point though at that point
it was already in my mind I was already
like yeah you weren't the one and I was
like she was the one for me as [__] up
as that sounds but yeah it was the one
so um
it is what it is so how did that lead
then to you getting into jewelry I was
thinking about opening up a small little
random One-Stop shop
Barber Shop buy some cool books maybe
get a couple pairs of cool sneakers but
like Basics like white and white Air
Force Ones it was like a just essential
things white teas certain things are you
coming in town all right boom this was
like a
um
a destination store sure like think
about going to LAX or going to JFK or
whatever boom but like no go here you're
gonna get a haircut you can get some
cool little trinkets get some yt's
and Ben Baller owns it with you know
cool people so I thought about that
'll be a few other things I was like nah
that ain't gonna work I had an exotic
car like really unorthodox Exotic Car
Rental thing that I was doing
and then my cousin hit me up
and I asked him I said what kind of
money is Joy making
the time he had a Corvette he had like
put all this money into it
he was killing it we had been always
talking about Joy until I needed jewelry
I get it from him I had a long talk with
him and his dad and then
he started Joy business how do you just
start a jewelry business like well
they're all Jewelers but how do you even
know like what looks good and what
what's I always had an eye for jewelry
you know what I mean and I was like Hey
listen
you guys are Jewelers
and I just know what sweat you know what
what what what what looks right
how's everything about this nah that
ain't cool it's like no [__] you
don't get it I'm gonna make this cool
I'll bring this back this is lit you
[__] weren't you while you guys
were out golfing and doing other [__]
you were not in the streets like me you
know what the real hood [__] is I'm
talking about universally what we could
do yeah yeah sure whatever next you know
like Mariah Carey Travis Barker like you
know the game Nas I'm just sort of
gathering big names how do they find you
I was in the music business
so you know I would start reaching out
to people my boy was dating Mariah Carey
at the time he produced her album
it's crazy because he was going through
it he's just he just finished his
divorce it's like six months before me
and it's like a crazy thing
but um Mariah Carey is enormous she's
you know gonna be
top three biggest female stars ever in
history right so like that was a big
plug
so how does it work do you make
something specific for them yeah of
course she got an MC chain her logo do
you give it to them at that point
because them wearing it like Mariah
Carey yeah you know I was good I was one
of the people that was really good at
doing very little promo yeah like I
wasn't gonna just cop [__] 25
000 30 40 000. I was able to just build
this brand out of the hood
and like get people attracted to it and
I built hype and I built the marketing
thing behind it so who's the first
famous person to take a chance on you
and say you know I'm gonna buy something
from Ben Baller Travis Barker Travis
Barker yeah and how did you get
connected with him was it just music
I've known Travis Forever yeah he was
him and DJ and we're in a group together
you know so Travis and you know whatever
and just we were always I've known
Travis Forever so what was the piece you
made for him it was just grills it was
grills the first chain I made for a
famous person was Fat Joe and Fat Joe
was always known for jewelry he was
always here and there whatever boom he
introduced me to so many other people
then the game then the game made his
[__] song about double game change
and I'm saying on his second album his
sophomore album that was enormous still
went you know two or three times
Platinum and it just literally
steamrolled from there and how much
what's up what's a profit margin on
something like that like how much does
it cost to make what's the time involved
and like it depends I was able to make a
chain in like three weeks to a month
which is like really fast I can make a
chain in 10 days if I needed to
scientifically like get one but it was
just I didn't want to put myself without
stress I have four deadlines for TV
shows and stuff but let's say for
instance if I'm gonna charge somebody
50k for a chain
back then I would say my profit and me
and my cousin will spending 50 50. I
would say like maybe like 10 to 12 000.
okay so it was a pretty good profit
margin you know what I'm saying like now
if I make a change for 50k today I'd
have to take at least 10 or 15 just by
myself sure because it's my name alone
right so like when I was doing minimums
for like
200 000 250 whatever
some people wouldn't have an idea for a
chain that was that was gonna cost more
than 60 70k so that right there you got
to give me 160 just because my name's on
it yeah how did you connect with people
like Justin Bieber
Justin reached out to me
through I kind of feel Sean Kingston if
somebody someone reached out to me amen
just me wants to meet you that was a
long time ago bro this was a long time
ago and funny thing was Justin had like
a like a low-key crush on my wife
and at the time a lot of people were
Googling Asian Kim Kardashian
and a lot of people even said even I
remember me and my wife were going to
the Polo Lounge in Beverly Hills
and I ran into Kim Kim just finished
having a gym she's like hey what's up
blah blah and then Kim was like oh this
is your girlfriend I was like yeah boom
Kim I told Rob her brother I was like
Ben's girlfriend looks [__] a lot
like me it was like a weird thing you
know
so then I remember a studio engineer
told me he was like yo and Justin when
you left Justin Google Asian
congratulations
that's not a good thing right but yeah
me and Justin just connected I ended up
making grills for him for the first time
and then we just end up I mean I took
Justin to Korea for the first time like
we've always been cool yeah been friends
with Justin for
11 12 years I think something like that
yeah it's been cool for a while so I'm
curious when people mention you in uh
their lyrics like Ferg is the name Ben
Baller did the change they reach out to
you ahead of time and so ask her it just
shows up when Dan you're surprised first
time I heard playing I heard playing
Jane was like in January 2016 2017 sorry
this song didn't even Scorch until like
summer mid-summer 2017. by October it
was like already major Platinum yeah and
like it's one of what four songs of
hip-hop history in rap history sorry
it's one of the only four rap songs of
gone diamond 10 million sold
so I'm like whoa like to this day you go
to any nightclub that song is being
played not away I don't give a [__] if
you're in
Tuscaloosa you could be anywhere I was
in Shanghai
and that [__] was playing and I was like
what was your initial reaction to that I
was like all right cool whatever no big
song
it blew up and got caught catchy
still even when it was starting to get
hot in the summer I was like you know
whatever cool ah cool whatever no big
deal
when it became that big it was like
monotonous
I was like oh [__] this is big turned
into a brand name you know how did that
impact business afterwards because for
me that's one of the most recognizable
lyrics of that song yeah it took things
to a whole different level I I
skyrocketed after that it's like who
reaches out to you afterwards everyone
you could think of really yeah and then
how do you pick who to because you
obviously don't have the capacity to
give it you know whatever random people
here and there it was cool it was it was
a good run
it was a good run it's still you know it
still trickles off now you know you
mentioned that you're friends with
people like Justin Bieber I mean you
went to Shanghai with him how do you
Korea or Korea sorry why do you go or
how you go from like a business type
relationship to an actual friendship
type relationship with these people I
think that just happened organically you
know what I mean he just wanted to he
just [__] with me you know like he was
he just knew like I was a big I was in
his dad by a year I'm older than Jeremy
by here
um I just think that he thought I was
wise I was cool had a lot of style and
um trusted me
he was going to Korea same time I was
and I was like all right pull up on me
sure enough he pulls up like hey bro
you gotta chill the [__] out you way too
wild right now you know like it was a
trip I've been always been cool and then
you know he started golfing not that
long ago I started golfing pretty
recently he's actually been golfing way
longer than me but he got the bug again
and we started golfing and stuff and um
I think
either I click with you or I don't like
ASAP Rocky like we clicked you know off
top certain people click and I own a
company with that with with Rocky and
you know you just uh
again if alignment
you know how seriously do you take
Marketing in terms of your own name and
business you've built a brand I don't
think I don't think you could take it
more seriously not take it honestly and
what do you do specifically because it
seems on my end it's very effortless and
it seems like more of a relationship
based business it's got to be effortless
because it's like golf yeah the harder
you try to swing the club
the shorter the ball is going to go the
distance won't go the same I never
understood that concept because if you
punch somebody soft in the face it's not
gonna land hard scientifically it won't
when you hit somebody you know you you
throw a ball at a glass
at a certain point depending on how the
class is you'd have to throw it pretty
hard or it has to be a lot of ball speed
and pressure yeah
with golf
this dude named Bryson D Shambo
start really breaking down the science
of a ball
the way you hit it you could hit it so
soft and the actual Club head speed
meaning how hard the how fast the club
was spinning she was getting the ball to
go further than people who had much
higher Club head speed
and now there are people who have very
high club and speed very high ball speed
what I'm saying is like it was just it
was effortless and you could play better
golf that way if you're more relaxed
I think if I don't go out there and try
so hard
with marketing
if you're out chasing somebody hey man
you're gonna get a chain hey bro I'm
hurting you in a few weeks you come in
here you're doing it all right boom you
could be annoying like that in certain
things where people owe you money
whatever and it just makes things worse
and and generally it does sometimes it
works for people sometimes it doesn't
for me
I think that's the point where I retire
I just completely just stop or do
something different you know like if I
have to chase somebody down to get a job
or get something that's like it just
ain't gonna work yeah you know either I
think at this point that's why I say it
was like 10 15 20 years in the making
where I am now
so as I gather along and gather all
these [__] you know all this game and
and all this um
knowledge and experience I'm only
getting better as time goes by
I'm not getting worse you know I mean
I'm not getting my memory is a little
off here and there but you know um
it would benefit you to to you know what
I'm saying [__] with me on a marketing
thing sure can you say what the nicest
piece of jewelry is that you've
commissioned you know that's a whole
always a hard thing to say but I think
that Kid Cudi has to have the the he had
he holds the the top dog rain like I
just think
the murakami collaboration and the cause
collaboration that these are official
actual artist pieces that are Museum
pieces you can't beat that you know
these would be forever
this would be forever how much is
something like that worth I mean I think
his cost piece is probably up in the
couple million now it's you know how do
you Source diamonds that's easy I mean
that's crazy millions of dollars yeah
that's easy no is it because of the cut
and Clarity or is it because there's so
many of them it's a combination of the
cut and Clarity and all that I think the
actual piece itself it was melted down
in a pawn shop you know be like maybe
five six hundred K sure but the fact
it's one of the most famous street
artists you know in well-known artist
period you know cause has paintings that
are out there in the millions already
you know so it's like his fan base that
and everything else now this is a
commission 101 piece there's actually in
his book you know he has an artist proof
of it you know Takashi murakami same
thing you know these things are being
shown in museums like this is a
different level of what we're doing here
so that right there is a big deal now I
heard you say recently I think a year
ago that you said that you're doing
fewer pieces now but you're making more
money
overall than doing you know like what
you were doing like five six years ago
well I'm not doing jewelry and I haven't
done jewelry in a year so so I'm just
not doing Joy at all I've pivoted in the
call full time you know what I mean in
podcasting so I mean if there's a favor
for somebody and they want me to make a
ring for them sure I do it
if more call me or calls want me to come
out of retirement and make something for
them I'd do it but I'm not doing jewelry
anymore so why'd you decide to get out
of jewelry and Duke off I had no
passionate anymore what happened it's
just like I just I think I just lost I
just another thing too is I'll be honest
with you Instagram ruined it for me
social media ruined it for me I think
seeing all the thirsty Jewelers out
there just want to become famous from it
I'd rather be well known for the pieces
the quality and then being known for
celebrities or whatever else you know I
could have made [__] XYZ for
literally XYZ
if they're fresh they're fresh they
don't got to be tied to a [__]
celebrity's name you know when I had my
reality show they're like it shows gonna
be celebrity driven and I'm like it
should be [__] character driven and
I'm the celebrity because I'm funny and
all these [__] right but that's
cool let's just keep it rocking
when it finally came time you know to be
on my time and my clock
and um
I just felt like
seeing where the jewelry world was going
I was like I can't do this [__] ain't
for me
what direction was going just do you say
it's mostly it's just saturated and it
just yeah just it is all Cloud all this
other [__] it's all cap it's all
[__] it just literally just lies man
you know what I mean it's just like oh
this piece was amazing shut the [__] up
bro no it's not you know what though
great I'm not gonna hate on you go do
your thing I just didn't want to be a
part of it anymore sure I'm curious how
difficult was it for you to walk away
from I guess the notoriety the money uh
and the fame that came along with making
such high-end custom jewelry and
deciding that you know I'm tired of it
was that a difficult decision for you or
were you at a point financially where
it's like hey it doesn't make sense no I
I think to be honest with you let me get
brutally honest yeah I think I actually
hurt my marriage right and it and it
created what's going on now with my life
with uh with the um
um
what's the [__] word you see it when
you get through the divorce I forgot
dissimulation or whatever or just a
solution
yeah it had
um
a decent part to do with the dissolution
of my marriage right so um I think
I truly fell out of love with it you
know now the thing is
I've never counted out and said I'll
never do it again that's not at all I
could easily go back and come and be Top
Dog and whatever
um if there's an opportunity for me to
do something that makes sense I got no
problem come back to it but how much I
fell in love with golf was like you
can't compare like it's ridiculous
yeah so you found something else that
you love more and then it's like well
between the two I love doing this I'm
gonna be honest and you saw the way that
the jewelry culture was going and you
didn't really it was been going to [__]
it been going to [__] and why I see
where golf is going I was like look
I could enter this place and change the
entire landscape of golf and the stigma
behind this old rich white Country Club
you know
reputation and open the game up what is
it about golf have you ever golfed
before I have yeah what'd you think
I'm not that athletic and I gotta say
after 18 holes of golf you are exhausted
but I'd start early like you get there
there's no golf muscles yeah so think
about that there's nothing natural about
a golf swing yeah so you're going to be
so regardless yeah there's really no
muscle memory I could do nine holes yeah
that's where you bow out it's a little
too much I've done 18. right did you
have it harder or did you walk I had a
cart
it gets it gets a lot to it now you know
but I think
one of my marketing things with my golf
merch and stuff is golf will always be
there for you
I wish I did it when I was 12 11 10 with
my kids you know how they're playing now
I wish I did it during the pandemic even
found it so late in life
but the thing about golf is there's so
many [__]
parallels to actual real life
getting in trouble in golf getting out
of trouble you find out so much about
yourself in a golf
course when you're by yourself because
there's no one else to save you there's
no one else that's going to help you you
know what I mean you cheat golf all
right you cheat in life you cheat
yourself
there's so many different ways of doing
things
I don't like walking the course I would
say I've walked a course less than 10
times
mostly for a prom or tournament right
when you do walk a course though you get
to think about your shots you gotta have
a short-term memory in golf you have a
bad shot if you think about that
[__] you're [__] you know
gotta keep it moving
I think when I turn 50
I was like all right the front nine was
pretty decent it was all right there
were some rocky Parts there's some good
parts in there's some double bogeys or
some triple bogeys there's some
quadruple bogeys
I had an ace I had some birdies had an
eagle
I'm on the back nine of my life now
so let's [__] go let's turn this up
you know how do you find it what do you
mean golf George Lopez had asked me to
come to his tournament a couple times I
never really cared and I was like you
know what [__] it I'm Gonna Come Taylor
me reached out to me I ended up having a
deal with them later
and just they all everything came
together and when I say it came together
I was like imagine like playing Lego or
something everything's just like oh
there's oh that piece is right here okay
everything just felt together this might
sound stupid but when you're there by
yourself are you listening to music or
is it just like no phone just like
silence just you and your thoughts I
think a lot of times there are times
where I do play music here and there
I think I just think about my life yeah
and I go back and go about all the pain
that's been happening and I think about
um
I think for most of my life I ran from
the pain and ignored it
and now I'm all about let me get the
feels let me not sweep anything under
the rug all that [__] ends up being
bigger problems later right like a
cavity don't let that [__] get into a
root canal don't let that [__] end
anymore say more serious right
and I just think that on the golf course
I'm just sitting there just really just
marinating going over things going over
life like all right but at the same time
you can't have any of that [__] in your
swing thoughts cause you're gonna
[__] shank the ball chunk it thin it
whatever
you got to be out there and really just
be disciplined and be pure so it's a lot
man and what about having kids very
curious because you've mentioned several
times how having children has really
affected the way you view life I'd love
for you to talk a little bit about that
like like having your your firstborn how
does that shift your mentality when it
comes to business and motivation and
like your priorities one it's not about
you anymore yeah I think I've been
selfish for most of my life also been a
very generous person it's kind of weird
right imagine a dude who toxic gang of
[__]
like imagine Donald Trump
it doesn't matter I'm not going to talk
about left or right at all because
people think I'm something else and I
actually am right as far as politically
I'm really down the middle I think now
right I don't really care I don't think
Biden's a great president whatever we're
not going to get in politics but what
I'm saying is imagine if Donald Trump
was actually a really good person in
general as well though he was doing a
ton of Charity doing all this stuff
there booming it just
with a kid
it's not about you anymore
people feel to realize that they did not
ask to be be here in the world
they are complete your responsibility
for at least 20 years or so right
you have so much
true responsibility can't leave a kid in
the car you can't you know what I'm
saying certain things at least until
like 13 or 14 right to be homes alone
and like you think about all right well
that's another mouth to feed
then you have a second kid [__] then you
have a third kid not only is it three
miles to feed it's to be clothing it's
this women you know girls are twice
three times the price of a boy tuition
[__] like that
if that doesn't light a fire under your
ass I don't know what will
because now you've put you know more
Rent One Mortgage whatever the [__] it
is you know so it's a lot schooling is
expensive in La yeah so how do you
balance that you just find like a good
private school yeah they've been prep
school since they're born so yeah okay
it sucks it's it's it's you know I wish
they could go to public school yeah I
wish like you know I mean I thought
about being in Beverly Hills and being
like you know at least they go there
but I don't even know if I want to go to
Beverly Hills you know I don't know man
is there any part of you that's worried
in the sense that you've become so
successful that your children have to
live up to that nah
I'd like them to I tell you I want my
kids to be happy man I think about it
you know um
I don't want to put it out there like
that like it's a negative thing but like
you know people in their family have
been like oh your dad's rich like no
we're not
I can't I never think like I'm rich I've
never told anybody I'm Rich As [__] Yeah
never said that before
I've done that before when I had like
ten thousand dollars in the bank you
know what I mean I'm like I've got money
done
it wasn't where I was yeah I'm like nah
bro we all right we do cool
what's quarter million dollar watch
black so what it's for sale you want it
do you get what I mean like I just
wasn't there
and I think early on I remember driving
him to school preschool Nursery School
they get dropped off at a Ferrari
Lamborghini or something when they start
going to school school even my wife was
like yeah why don't you just being a
McLaren go take it like you know [__] it
like these kids are flossing their
parents flossing Ferrari and stuff like
yeah
they've never even picked up anything
crazy at school
so just like that ain't that I don't
want that I don't want that they're
already right now
for the first time now their kids are
starting to realize that their dad's
popular mm-hmm we're on vacation in
Hawaii and we've been up they see people
asking all the time for pictures
I don't protect their PR I'm not super
proud about their life I just don't post
my house on certain things before they
go to school but like
we're walking in downtown Waikiki Beach
and we can stop 40 times in an hour they
know their dad's like you know I'm not
Mr Beast but they know what time it is
you know
so yeah that's pretty cool I mean think
about it like Drake and Bieber and all
these people since they were born I've
been giving them birthday shout outs and
doing videos and coming up to their
birthday parties it's like you know it's
like they kind of know sure like
randomly like two months ago well this
one was like Dad listen you know Justin
Bieber I was like yeah of course what do
you mean he [__] came to your
birthdays he does birthday videos for
you and stuff and so finally went to his
Instagram page like this is you and
Justin right here he's like oh [__] kids
are trying to really be like oh wow
that's crazy yeah like my middle son's
obsessed with Michael Jackson
I was like Daddy made all his Joy last
year of his life
he's like whoa what was Neverland like
you know it's like they're super sharp
man you know so that's kind of it's got
to be kind of cool to be able to share
that with them now yeah for sure and Mr
Beast was gonna do something with me for
my sons they're obsessed with them as
well and I was a big I'm gonna ask you
I'm gonna be honest with you
out of every favor I could think of from
a celebrity
whether it be Drake singing at my
wedding whatever it is
that was probably the hardest thing to
get that was harder than anything I've
ever done in my entire life that was
harder than anything and I think about
it now yeah she's so big at this point
that he could ask Apple to do something
for him that's how big it is he's trying
to do that right now with streaming
platforms no I mean like he could
literally have a Mr Beast that guy he's
that powerful I think it's like you know
so like
just so it's just it's just crazy you
know yeah it's crazy now that uh the
power that YouTubers have had at this
point I wouldn't even consider Mr Beast
a YouTuber
yeah yeah and I'm not a huge fan of
YouTube but yeah my kids are have you
found though that after having kids
maybe you've been safer in your own life
and more conservative in terms of like
your Investments and what you spend and
like definitely for sure I think I think
not even in in even in a political term
if you really think about having kids
how do you not think
conservatively and I mean that in all
aspects of the term of the definition of
of conservatives yeah even from being a
Republican or whatever just as far as
like what you want for your children and
stuff right
um and again I'm not a political person
I'm sure I have been Ultra cautious
about what it is
so you know if someone sees me spending
a bunch of money here
know that either someone paid for that
or
there was a lot saved to [__] off that
one little thing here and there you know
I wasn't those dudes in the pandemic was
like look [__] this I never really see
outside again we're gonna spend all our
money I was like what the [__] are you
doing but um financially last year was a
bad year for me
and no one would ever know unless I'm
telling you now you know but I think
also me pivoting into a whole different
world it's going to take a little time
I've never been a patient person
I'm like all right cool I'm gonna start
a company all right two weeks gone by
all right are we a billion dollar
company yet not what
come on you know like I understand it
takes some time and even what I'm doing
with golf yeah what I've done in a year
and some change
people don't do in seven years so why
was last year A bad year financially
because I completely stopped making
jewelry the jewelry was the sole driver
of your income because at that point I'm
just saying like it's it's a lot of
money even jobs based off my jewelry was
getting me jewelry you know what I'm
saying like whether it be a sponsor with
it with a brand they want to tie it to
some jewelry thing you know and I was
like let me just did you reach like a
net worth or something where you could
say I'm comfortable walking away from
this that you know no matter what I now
I have the freedom to do whatever I want
to do in life I think a few years ago I
did okay and then it wasn't like it
wasn't enough because of what's going on
now do you know what I mean you realize
it's like you know
I mean honestly yeah you know I thought
I'd be married forever so that's also a
weird thing but at the same time I've
never spoke about this because it's
still so fresh and new I have no idea
what's gonna happen yeah you know what I
mean the Incas and try it I have no idea
and I'm not even opening a possibility
because my mind is not there but I never
know what's gonna happen because
the last
two and a half three months have been so
[__] insane
that who knows
you know what happened if that's insane
there
you know what happens now I don't know
at what point did you decide to go
through also with losing losing weight
what fed into that May June last year I
was like look
I got 214 during the pandemic
and I just this is just not it I think
also a certain point again my wife was
like yellow man your belly is too
[__] big it's like this ain't sexy
this ain't this and she was like can you
just one time before you know blah blah
whatever and I think she was a big
driver to it but I think about like
what's going through my life right now
if I was 200 something right now I would
be probably in a way way worse place
fact that I feel great that I'm walking
on the course and I'm slim I can take my
shirt off I'm like tripping like when I
was in Hawaii like two months ago or so
like I I just feel quite slim you know
like I was like look this is really
where I need to be yeah how'd you do it
intermittent fasting straight up just
amazing about that I was doing um 1410
not stuck with that for a while I'm at
12 12 now what does 1410 mean
14 hours I do not eat nothing 10 hours I
eat so pretty much let's say for
instance 8 P.M is my last meal after
that I can only have water or tea
nothing that would break a fast
and then my first meal would be at 10
A.M the next day so at 10 A.M I have my
coffee with milk with sugar with cream
whatever the [__] it is have a bagel
have a pizza for lunch have a burger
have steak have french fries have some
candy drink soda all day long APM is
gonna stop I kept that I couldn't
believe it now the thing is it come it's
very slow
you might not see any results for like
four or five months whereas I could do a
[__] Atkins or you know carb free
diet but I could lose 25 pounds in three
weeks the thing is this
as soon as you [__] up that way it's
coming back instantly it's water weight
it's [__] right now it'll take me
like five six months to get the weight
back it'll take me even longer now I'm
talking about just eating like a [__]
piece of [__] I was eating at 1am I'm
smoking weed eat all day night one two
in the morning and just like eat
whatever the [__] I want now I just do
it within that schedule yeah why was
that like stress eating or was that like
the habits because you're crazy just bad
habits
just bad habits throughout life I think
if you really added up how much you
stacked throughout the day you'd be
surprised no late nights I know exactly
how bad it was yeah because I look at
myself now you know interesting yeah how
are you keeping yourself calm collected
right now with everything going on do
you meditate is it golf is it do you
find an outlet through business you know
man I've asked all my friends who are
very successful in business I've gone
through divorces and they're like
I just drowned myself in work and I know
that wasn't it
because I'd be too emotional at work so
I think
one thing about me is I'm a homebody but
at the same time it's different when
you're at home alone
right or you don't have the kids that
week or whatever
and um I've never been through this this
level of mental toughness in my life
um
so
again going back to the kids yeah
I don't really have a choice
you know because they need me
and um
that's where the toughest struggle is
and I think I haven't lost it
I've had the I think there have been
times where I lost it for way less
reason
I think
talking to the right people
has helped me a lot but I went through
the darkest time of my life probably
two months ago I probably hit the the
rock bottom of all 50 years of my living
on this Earth I don't think I've been to
a darker place in my life
and then about a week ago it kind of
came back a little bit and
about two months ago I was drying my
kids to Dave and Busters
I looked over to
all three of them and I said
I would die for you
like what I was like I would literally
take a bullet for you guys I understand
you know like it's easy to say but I
like you know you really mean it like I
would die for you guys I would sacrifice
my life for you
my middle son Rider looked at me and he
goes
I couldn't [__] believe it was coming
out of eight-year-old's mouth he was
like
but then Dad who would guide us through
life and I'm like going through a
parking lot and I stop dead
and I pulled over I was like wow
because he knew it couldn't be his
grandfather he knew it couldn't be his
uncle he knew it couldn't be anybody
that his mom's friends with or anyone
I'm friends with you know could it be
maybe his mom
he's trying to be a man he meant it
deeper than just saying like you know
because he elaborated a little bit more
and I was like [__] man
he's like you know we know how hard you
work you know what we know you were gone
a lot
I think early on for a long time you
know my wife my wife's been a
stay-at-home mom for 10 plus years
so like you know of course they're with
her so much and I was gone a lot there
was one year I was gone 190 180 days out
of the year I was going and then you
know right when the pandemic finally
opened up I was starting to go again
I think that definitely [__] some
things up
but right now
I have the strongest relationship with
my children I've ever had in my entire
life
like when I say strong I'm talking like
it's a different level yeah
you know like they'll go psycho without
me you know what I'm saying like they're
they're like heavy with me right now so
that right there is really the only way
to keep calm because I think about that
yeah you know they seem great by the way
they're so polite oh my gosh and they
walked and they're they're they're in a
bad they're they're they're they're
they're they're kind of acting bad today
man but yeah I I don't see it oh my gosh
I was so shy as a kid they're coming up
like introducing themselves like seems
so confident yeah yeah that's fine and
that's it's a rare thing because my
oldest one has gone through so many
health issues you know he just came out
of his shell like
this past year I mean up to I mean eight
months ago where he didn't really speak
at all that's incredible so you probably
gotta go yeah I gotta get okay hey thank
you so much thank you really appreciate
it appreciate it this was an honor man
you have no idea thank you so much man
appreciate it man I told him to be 40
minutes oh [__] sorry sorry yeah